c'était au vésinet le 11 janvier dernier
un jeune de 16 ans se rendant au lycée
un vélo décède des suites d'un accident
avec un poids lourd ce drame survenu sur
la route de croatie a choqué la
population qui s'est mobilisée pour
alerter sur les dangers de cet axe de
passage
une pétition a été lancée rassemblant
près de trente mille signataires elles
demandent l'amélioration urgente des
conditions de circulation pour les vélos
au vésinet en plus d'alertés bien sûr
nous voulons qu'ils aient des choses
concrètes
on demande que les allées les camions du
chantier soit arrêtée pendant les
horaires de l'école on veut une piste
cyclable provisoire pour les enfants et
aussi que les chauffeurs de camion
connaître l'itinéraire pour ne plus
prendre les petites rues du vésinet la
route est très peu aménagé son trafic
important aux heures de pointe rend
l'accès encore plus dangereux alors que
c'est une voie rapide d'accès au lycée
pour les élèves
il ya un petit peu tout je dirais que
c'est la concentration qui fait la
dangerosité 1
donc il ya les voitures qui sont garés
il ya les bus les camions les lycéens
qui sont pressés d'aller aux cours
donc tout ça dans une période en fait
très très limité malgré tout entre 7h30
et 8h30
des contacts ont été établis entre les
parents d'élèves et la mairie du vésinet
afin de discuter des dispositifs à
mettre en place comme axe principal
d'études interdire la circulation des
camions qui transitent sans autorisation
et remarques qui sont faits dans cette
pétition sont extrêmement justifier on y
adhère d'ailleurs à 100% ça correspond
parfaitement un autre un autre à notre
philosophie est un autre projet et que
on s'est mis d'accord avec le promoteur
immobilier enfin avec remparts et
aménagements pour pour qu' en plus de
cette contravention de police municipale
et une pénalité qu'ils soient appliqués
aux promoteurs kessy encore une récidive
c'est le contrat est cassé et le
le marché le marché est arrêté d'autres
mesures à court et moyen terme sont
envisagées créer un circuit vélo
alternatif renforcer la signalisation
pour ensuite construire une piste
cyclable des objectifs déjà énoncées
dans le programme de la liste électorale
de bruno corps à des ti élus lors des
dernières municipales avec
fondamentalement le développement des
pistes cyclables devraient puisse aussi
que la mauvaise idée après simplement
des tracés sur la route assurer la
sécurité des cyclistes la sécurité des
piétons et donc à terme revoir tout le
plan de circulation et surtout limiter
la vitesse très fortement à l'intérieur
du vésinet des dispositifs à mettre en
place en urgence avec les retards de
chantier sur la zone
le trafic risque encore d'augmenter
jusqu'à juin